all right let's go to bj and appleton i
have a son who
has a drug addiction um i've been
struggling with it for as far as i know
six to seven years um his father died
unexpectedly when he was 16. i hate that
right after i he turned 16
and things started to go backwards after
that
um and i'm to a point where
this this roller coaster he's put
everyone on with his addiction
i'm tired i'm exhausted how old are you
bj uh fifth size 55
and how old is he now 27 27
is he married does he have little ones
he has two kids
two kids are they in a safe place
yes yeah do they live with him with
their mom
with their mom okay
so your sons had lost after loss after
loss huh
yeah yeah and you've had loss after loss
after loss huh
yeah yeah so can i tell you this
bj you're allowed you're allowed to be
exhausted
thank you you're allowed to be super
frustrated and heartbroken
and pissed off and sad and heartbroken
again and again and again
are some things you've tried to connect
with your son
i'm just just for the people listening
to this what are some things you've gone
through to try to connect with him
um he's been through group sessions and
counseling and rehab then
i've been there with him you know i've
attended his rehabs i've attended his
group sessions
you know i visited him when he was in
jail
i always always let him know i love him
and support him and i'm there for him
and he so he has the tools from
uh previous group sessions and and
counseling sessions
he knows what to do he just won't do it
um
and i've told him several times i think
if he saw a therapist
and talked about the demons
that haunt him it would do a great deal
for him
but he just he doesn't do it do you see
somebody i do
is that helpful it is very much
so you're at a place now where no parent
wants to be
and i'm just gonna be honest with you
and and tell you the truth okay
there's absolutely nothing you can do
for your son other than continue to love
him
and to draw firm boundaries that keep
you safe and you well and you whole
he's you can't make him see a counselor
and i know you know these things and i'm
telling you
i'm saying these things out loud for the
listeners as much for you but
until he decides he wants to get well
and whole he's not going to get well and
whole
and anything in between that is
performance right it's and it's going to
fall down
and it's real frustrating that he won't
get clean for his kids
it's real frustrating that he won't get
clean for his ex it's real frustrating
he won't get clean for you
but he won't i know i know and he's an
adult he's an adult i can't
make him do anything but it's still that
uh mama bear mentality that wants to
love him and protect him and help him in
any way i can and it's frustrating
to just stand and watch it is the
the best way you can love him right now
is to take care of yourself
and that means sitting down with your
therapist and say i'm ready to draw
hard hard boundaries i'm ready to
create a life reverse engineer a life of
where i want to go
where i want to be not that just
constantly in response to my son
and his addiction his challenges
and you build that world back
and that may not include him very much
who knows when he's going to decide to
turn it around he's had a supportive mom
my guess is even before your husband
passed away there's probably some demons
way back there that he's
experienced that he's working through
but man that's tough loving an addict
i can't think of no other thing because
it's like having a funeral to someone
who's still walking around
and for you this is a loss on top of a
loss you lost your husband
you lost your partner in crime you lost
your marriage
and now you're watching a ghost of your
son walk around and it's heartbreaking
and i wish i had better news for you
other than you've got permission to be
exhausted you've got permission to
at 55 build that life
and you can it's not too late and you're
not going to not have a hole in your
heart
and you're not going to not hurt
desperately
but you can begin to work towards the
places you want to go
the person you want to continue to
become the grandmother those two baby
girls that you want to become
you can work towards that and hope upon
hope and pray upon prayer
that he falls down on his face and
decides i'm ready
i'm ready to go see somebody i'm ready
to do the hard trauma work
and work through this stuff because i'm
worth it my kids are worth it my mom is
worth it
my future's worth it but love comes with
risk
and it's hard
i hate that for you bobby joe i hate it
for you
i can't i can't i can't think of
anything worse i mean i'm wrapping my
head around i guess
the death of a child is is the
worst thing a parent can ever experience
but close to that
is an addicted child and if you're
listening to this and you've got
addiction problems if you've got a mom
or dad who didn't treat you right if you
got a mom and dad who did treat you
right
hear me say you are worth getting well
man
you're worth not having to use you're
worth not having to eat you're worth not
having to fill in the blank for your
addiction
and it's gonna be hard to get there
but it's worth the the journey
it's worth those hard conversations it's
worth those hard counseling sessions
it's worth
painfully changing your behaviors and
falling down and scraping your knees and
your face and hurting relationships and
getting back up and getting back up and
getting back up but it's worth it
it's worth it it's worth it and i hope
you heard
the exhaustion in bj's voice hope you
heard the
she's tried and she's tried and she's
tried
but doing it for somebody else isn't
gonna work you gotta do it for yourself
and you gotta know that you're worth it
we have a culture that is so addicted to
everything
so you're worth being well you're worth
being well thank you so much for that
call
thank you so much for that call bj